gie America but given what happened over
the weekend in Orlando I'd want to spend
a minute on that as I'm sure you would
as well and I'll be a little personal at
this because when I was running ABC News
I remember after Columbine we came down
and you did a live to our program with
your wife if you recall with a town
meeting and I remember how emotional
that was and how difficult was that job
when there's been tragedies huge
tragedies hit the country what can we do
to avoid this going forward well first
of all we we need more help so with
intelligence work with federal and local
law enforcement with people who may be
lone wolves it's like those people at
San Bernardino they were converted to
their ideology over the Internet today
we still don't know all I think we'll
eventually learn about the man who
killed all the people in Orlando but
it's you know there are all kinds of
crazy theories floating around now but
it does seem pretty clear that some of
the people who were in touch with him
beforehand perhaps even in his own
family knew he was going to do something
whether they knew this or not so we've
got to get better at that and in our
fellow to help us
because you have to take it seriously
the people just like it's it's also true
in other areas like we a lot of people
miss clear signs of suicides and this is
something new that's sort of you know
you can go down to your friendly store
and get an ar-15 and wipe out a bunch of
people we need tighter security on that
and then I think the other things that
Hillary said in her speech yesterday are
accurate to the other things we can do
to hardened our defenses at home and
increase our efforts around the world to
defeat Isis and other radical groups but
I kept thinking over and over the more I
hear about this is you know I was glad
to hear the FBI director saying he was
constantly asking himself is there
something else we should have done at
some point in this chain events that
would have done it that's what every
American should ask and we just got to
all be on a higher alert you can't
ignore someone you think is ranting and
raving they may be serious so you
mentioned what Secretary Clinton one of
the presumptive candidates said
yesterday we've also had the other
perception candidate come out and say at
least two things one is we should
exclude people from Muslim countries
from coming in because some of them have
this ideology and number two if we'd had
more people with guns in that nightclub
there wouldn't have it as bad a tragedy
what's your reaction to that do you see
how dark it was yes in the clink it's
likely that more people would have been
killed all I know is this
we had a ten year ban on assault weapons
and that was passed when I was president
I signed it and we pushed hard for it
and no small number of members of
Congress lost their jobs because they
voted for that and for what was then a
comprehensive background check law we
had a 33 year low in the gun death rate
and a 46 year low in total illegal
deaths by gun homicides in other words
it worked pretty well and then you know
when it was when it was allowed to
expire for a while we didn't seem to
have an uptick in crime but if you look
at what happened with these big weapons
at Sandy Hook in Aurora Colorado and
most recently in Orlando and San
Bernardino it's it's pretty clear that
the if you're firing a lot of weapons a
lot of ammunition in a short amount of
time with an weapon that's designed only
to kill more people will die then if
you're stuck with a pistol if the guy
had just had a pistol in that nightclub
I don't think anybody believes he could
possibly kill 49 people so that's my
response so let's talk about the CGI
America initiative and I we understand
generally about how it works but I want
to be specific because there's one
particular initiative that came out of
the meetings last year here in Detroit
as you know I'm from Michigan yeah I've
just been back to Detroit visiting
Detroit now take us through that
initiative having do with mortgages and
housing in Detroit and how it worked
well first of all Detroit was in a
unique situation because it was coming
out of bankruptcy at a vigorous new
Mayor Mike Duggan he really wanted to
help people move downtown in a hurry and
when he became mayor he was in effect in
control of more than 50% of the
and mass of downtown Detroit some of the
property needed to be razed and cleared
because they could use more green spaces
because it didn't seem likely that
anyone will come back to live there but
there were 10,000 he found 10,000
structurally sound habitable structures
and a lot of people were willing to
moved back downtown because they wanted
to help Detroit come back but they all
needed repairs the banks that would
issue the mortgage had to value the
homes based not only on their structure
some of them are quite magnificent even
but not only on their structural
potential but on the fact that they've
supported neighborhoods where area of
their house was vacant so people who
were willing to move downtown and
couldn't afford to both buy the home and
repair it needed to have more mortgage
help than any bank could legally give
them on the first mortgage so you know
the mayor talked about it and I have a
real interest in Detroit and wanted to
help and we physically located close to
each other in Detroit and some were from
out of town and they just put their
heads together for three days and they
came up with this idea of how a second
mortgage could be issued that would
enable the homeowner to make the home
habitable and that the repayment could
be structured in a way that would not
[ __ ] them financially and that's what
we did and it's going to put a thousand
more people in homes and I think it'll
be the beginning of something that may
well have application and other
distressed areas in the United States
and I hope so what was it that wouldn't
failed that didn't allow this to happen
I mean it wouldn't have happened as I
understand it without the city
would not have happened I mean
well-meaning people could not have
gotten together what is it what's the
failure in that well I think it's not so
much a failure as you shouldn't it's
almost impossible in a big complex
society with a zillion things happening
at once to set up a system that precedes
every potential breakdown or every
potential problem you know if we'd never
had the financial crash maybe these
banks could have thought that enough
slack from regulators to do something
that they clearly under strict his
conditions shouldn't have done so now
they couldn't do it so we figured out
how to basically close the gap in the
fabric of our housing market and that's
really what I was trying to do when I
set up my foundation 15 years ago I just
wanted to figure out how to solve
problems faster better at lower cost
than when they would otherwise be solved
and I saw this a lot there's a great
deal of difference between passing law
and changing lives it's a great deal of
difference between appropriating money
and changing lives you have to know how
to do things and I think that the more
complex and interdependent our society
gets the more premium we will put on
people who find a way to answer the how
question and we find and have for years
that if you get groups of people with
diverse experience and expertise who
just want to get a job done and don't
really care about what their politics
are or anything else they're just trying
to get a job done more often than not
you find a way to do it faster better at
lower cost as you say you have a track
record down you have a body of work what
have you learned over those years about
what sorts of problems particularly can
be addressed solved by this sort of
cooperative effort and which ones really
don't fit so well well
let's start with the second category
there are some things that require if
you will a threshold level of investment
from either the private sector or
government without which you can't do
what you'd like to do I'll give you an
example you told me you were from flat I
am flat is nowhere near the only city in
America where children have elevated
blood levels in their blood we've done
what we could to help Flint but it would
take a national commitment to a real
serious infrastructure program to take
up all the rusty pipes in America and
give all the kids in our country a
healthy future be a very good investment
interest rates are lower than inflation
now would create a lot of jobs and have
a good income there would still be
particular problems in particular places
we could help but that's a threshold
thing we can now because solar and wind
power are relatively cheap and
dramatically cheaper than they were a
few years ago we can help to put
together coalition's to accelerate the
income benefits as well as the climate
benefits of solar and wind power in many
places but if for example you want to
help the poorest Americans who are still
Native Americans living on Indian lands
without casinos a lot of them could be
making a fortune out of this but they
can't afford the transmission lines to
carry the power from where they are to
any place that's strong enough to
receive it so those are the things you
can do the things you can do largely
involve getting people to rethink what
they're doing and see if they can
be faithful to the to their
responsibilities with their assets and
do it in a way with more social benefits
I'll give you an example of I could give
you a lot to put out just one quick one
is I was having a conversation five
years ago with the president of the
afl-cio rich tropical in Davos of all
places I think it's the last time I was
there and I said you know Labor's under
a lot of stress but you don't have to
play victim here you need to play
offense and I think you should consider
taking your well-funded public pension
funds and investing money in
infrastructure projects especially
energy retrofits that will put a lot of
union workers to work on the private
sector and old pension funds and he just
sued on it and put me in touch with some
people and Randi Weingarten at the aft
wound up taken the lead with the North
American Building Trades group and we
got ten billion dollars in commitments
to do this now their commitment is 14
billion 14 and a half billion has been
allocated about 12 and a half has
actually been deployed spent and more
than a hundred thousand dollars have
been created doing these infrastructure
and building retrofit projects it's done
a world of good created a lot of jobs
it's the public pension funds have been
totally faithful the trustees who have
because they're going to get a decent
return on this and that's the kind of
thing I did we just think about all the
time how you how can you do something
differently coca-cola is one of the
hostess hosts of this CGI America they
joined with PepsiCo her big about how
about that yeah and Cadbury Schweppes
and other big producers of those soft
drinks and fruit juice and they agreed
to change what they were putting in the
drinks going to children in our school
both in the vending machines and the
cafeterias and with voluntary agreement
they reduce according to two different
independent studies they reduced the
calories going to kids and schools by
ninety percent that's the kind of stuff
I try to get people to do here so given
that track record given those
accomplishments looking forward to what
I think you probably expect and hope
will happen next November what happens
to your initiative Clinton Global
Initiative if your wife is president
well I think right now I just want to
say what Hillary did well it's across
that bridge when we come to it if she
wins we'll have to think about it there
clearly politics is different from what
I do I mean I you know I just try to get
partners together and make something
good happen the government should do
more of that and the the president is
tried to involve more people from the
private sector and a lot of his
decision-making but you have to be
careful to avoid actual or potential
conflict so that's the issue because the
people have raised that even Donald
Trump's raise that and things like that
and and lots of things get raised but it
gets dicey er you know we're like this
president we're thinking we'll think
very clearly about it we'll and we'll do
the right thing we'll try to and explain
it to the American people but I'll have
to wait first I don't believe in
counting your chickens before they hatch
and so let's see how this election
unfolds but they'll clearly be some
changes and what the Clinton Foundation
does and how we do it and we'll just
have to cross that bridge when we come
to it so talking about the election a
bit I mean you served as president for
eight years and there was a fair amount
of heated rhetoric I think it's fair to
say back and forth and up and down but
what we're seeing in this election
strikes me at least as having a level of
personal attack involved and it's not
uniquely on the Republican side there
have been some some candidates on the
Democratic side as well is this a
permanent change in the political
discourse in this country or is this an
aberration
I don't know it's easier to say things
that don't make a look a sense now
because so many of our people are siloed
and their information that is I tell
people all the time and notwithstanding
that terrible incident in Orlando we are
less racist sexist and homophobic than
we used to be
we just are where we're becoming a more
inclusive society one remaining bigotry
is we do not want to be around anyone
who disagrees with us either actually or
virtually so we are if you get into a
silo like that you're prone to believe
anything that your preconceived
prejudice would allow and that's not
good for us that's why one of the
reasons that I like all these CGI events
because people here come from every
political perspective they make a living
in different ways their whole experience
base is different and they find it quite
stimulating to be with people who are
different from them and they find that
what we know which is that diverse
groups make better decisions than lone
geniuses much less a group of totally
like thinking people so I think we just
have to be super sensitive to that and
keep looking for ways to to break out of
our silos because fundamentally people
are pretty decent but I do think if you
look around the world a lot of these
campaigns have gotten harsher and
harsher in part because of the long drag
after the crash so you've got in many
places a combination of stagnant incomes
and disruptive threats to people
identity and then Europe you had the
biggest refugee crisis since World War
two and you had a contest between walls
and bridges in Austria which is a very
solid economy it's still a pretty close
contest and I think you have a lot of
people who've if they go a long time
thinking that they can't make their
tomorrows better and they can't give
their kids a better
they feel consciously or subconsciously
that the world disrespects them
disregards them or doesn't see them so
then they're less offended if somebody
else is getting the kind of treatment
they think they their life gives them I
think that we all need to be a lot more
sensitive of that we need to be more
sensitive to what our neighbors are
going through and I think if we did that
it slowly we would change the culture
back to where our politics was a little
more humane and disciplined yeah I want
to talk about the economy and growing
the economy but before that one last
point on the election it strikes me that
one of the things have been injected
this time is questioning the opponent's
qualifications even to serve it's one
thing to say I disagree with them it's
another thing to say I'd be better than
they would be but to say they shouldn't
even be considered for office you have
held the office you have special
qualifications as you look at it what
should be the qualifications we're
looking for in a candidate whether
they're Republican or they're Democrat
well first of all that's the decision
that the voters make in every election
and different people serve better at
different times I was well suited to be
president when I was elected because I
was the senior governor in terms of
service in America and my state had one
of the fastest growing economies in the
country and had a big improvement of the
things that America need to improve on
including education and employment in
hard industries like manufacturing and
because I knew what was people were up
against but I think at a minimum you
want someone who
love the country believes that we are
not just a place where an idea that we
really do believe we're born to welcome
people from every place who love freedom
believe in the rule of law and respect
other people's right to play out their
destiny and then someone with a proven
record of being able to do that and then
you know we do have other rules that
develop over time that we think are
required so but the voters ultimately
decide that they decided you know I but
I think my job is to support one
particular candidate who I think is the
most qualified person in America to
serve at this particular time because
now we need someone who basically
understands how the federal government
can add a couple of points the economic
growth that can make more importantly
prosperity more widely shared to reduce
inequality and increase upward mobility
and as it can break the political
gridlock in Washington and give us a
space we need to grow this our economic
fate now it's pretty well tied up also
with what happens in the rest of the
world you know in the last quarters
economic report there was a great piece
of good news for the first time since
the crash more than 61 cents on the
dollar of corporate revenues was going
to pay in other compensation there's
about sixty two and a half cents wages
starting to rise and then a piece of bad
news which is that in spite of the brisk
hiring of several months our growth had
dropped back to a half a percent due
entirely to what's happening around the
world
Brazil China's slowing down pressures
and Southeast Asia all these things that
are going on and what's happening in
Europe so I think you know it's it's not
an easy job right now but it's a doable
one it's not so difficult to determine
what we should do is to pick people with
a skill sets to do it well that's
exactly what I as a good day from
Bloomberg world headquarters in New York
I'm mark Crompton we're interrupting our
interview with former President Bill
Clinton with my colleague David Westin
at the Clinton Global Initiative in
Atlanta President Obama is set to speak
on terrorism he is at the US Treasury
Department before we go to that event
let's go to my colleague Angela grayling
keen who's been following this story
today
Angela given the events in Orlando given
what happened last night outside of
Paris the authorities there believe that
a man who had allegiance to Islamic
state was responsible for the death of a
police official and his wife what can
the president say today that may allay
people